nor money will you go on a date with me
nor money it would be an honor to go on
a date with you now yes I will go out
with you all the way wait wait wait not
this week I got things to do this week
for maybe a week afternoon yes I'll
definitely go I would be able to see
your address where are you going on a
date what kind of menu there's gonna be
there's no drinking involved obviously
cuz she's up 121 at the end of the month
what's happening the couple leaving
right now is Simone and Sasha
so elimination big surprise I mean it's
incredible you never know what's gonna
happen but I know Simone she seems like
she's got like pretty good spirits
considering she's got great spirits
because she has no regrets you know I
think she's embraced the show got
everything out of it that she wanted you
guys have a special connection where you
keep it like my best friend you see this
kind of friendship being one that lasts
Oh forever for a lot 10 yet we're gonna
have a sleepover next week so what are
you gonna do with the finals the
Freestyle want to create a piece that I
think one last time celebrates no money
as a person that's passionate about the
world around her and and and just show
her gratitude for this opportunity and
hopefully pass the light along to the
next normani that's gonna be on our show
you